and and tomorrow really is because this
of course comes quite shortly after she
was cleared to take up the role uh uh by
the appointments Watchdog uh as secure
starman's new Chief of Staff does this
decision alter that at all what are the
implications uh no it doesn't there were
two separate processes going on
essentially
um kissed armor and was given the green
light to have Sue gray the um former
senior civil servant investigator of
partygate as his chief of staff starting
from September and that was by akoba
which is the body that vets appointments
of former ministers and Senior civil
servants they said that she had to wait
this six months period but the risks
were relatively small so that all goes
ahead and kirst armor welcomed it but
there had been a push in government for
it to be investigated as a breach of the
civil service code essentially heard
discussions with him because she told
this investigation that they had started
speaking back in October 20 22 and a
formal job offer was made in March of
this year and those conversations were
not declared so this was investigated by
by as and found according to the
statement we've just heard from the
government to be a breach of the code so
if she was still a civil servant there
might be sanctions or indeed a
suspension but now she has left it
doesn't look like there will be anything
now government sources tell me the
crucial thing about all this is that
this investigation was done by officials
not by ministers they're saying it's not
a political thing so if kirst armor
attacks it and then he's attacking
independent civil servants and
government lawyers but certainly it will
be a useful thing for the government to
throw at kirst Armor suggesting that he
has broken the rules when it usually
Kirsten leveling that accusation at the
government so no implications really for
Sue gray starting her work that is
expected to begin in September but um
the government's saying that rules were
broken in the process